it is truly stunning but
not surprising how quickly
the biggest anti-cancel culture
activists
have gone full cancel culture they seem
to have no shame
they seem to have no even understanding
of what they are doing
and it is amazing how quickly the
biggest advocates
for never regulating business are now
saying to businesses
what they can and should say and when
they should just
shut their mouths and say nothing fox
and friends
has been just one data point fox news in
general
has been just one data point of the
types that have been railing against
so-called cancel culture for months
freedom of speech is under attack
they want to cancel easter they want to
cancel prayer they want to cancel dr
seuss people and businesses are being
punished by the left for wrong think
and wrong speech and all of this stuff
and since the georgia voter suppression
bill
has led to vira various organizations
and businesses to say simply
we'd rather not do business with georgia
in georgia we're going to go somewhere
else instead
everybody has reversed donald trump
released his list of companies to
counter
boycott rand paul says boycott coca-cola
mitch mcconnell says corporate ceos
should shut up about politics but keep
donating to me
and now fox news isn't even pretending
anymore here is a segment in which they
ran a list of companies that have
criticized the georgia law
on a crawl up the screen and you will
notice
that what they are criticizing here
is criticizing speech speech
in which you criticize is just talking
it's speech and they are saying
punish these businesses for criticizing
which is another word for
speaking check out this clip let's look
at the list
other companies and organizations that
have criticized the georgia voting law
now we're not saying that they're
boycotting
but they're criticizing and that's where
these things sometimes can start i say
sometimes we can't tell the future
but you know from what what you're
saying atlanta
all of georgia can be hurt by these
decisions and i want to point out
who did their homework on denver who did
their homework on colorado compare the
voter laws
i don't know guys i'm starting to think
that the right
may not be sincere about their supposed
values
of free speech and of businesses doing
what they want without punishment and
being against cancellation and being
against boycotts
it's almost like they only advocate for
these values when it's convenient
and when it doesn't conflict with
whatever else they want and then they
will quickly abandon the values when it
does
and by the way their list is now
way bigger than any list i've ever seen
on the left which is like a
it's an insignificant but also
compelling little detail
this is a list that the left can use
though if you want i'm not saying do
this
but you could if you want you could
look at that list that fox news crawled
and you could contact
those very same companies and say
i support what you were doing in
speaking out against
voter suppression that's speech you
could use
to counter their speech meant to counter
the corporate speech
which is part of the fight against voter
suppression consider
how absurd it is when people
get boycotts going against fox news
advertisers fox news hosts and right
wingers and trump and all
they say that's bad that's cancel
culture
but then the next thing you know fox
news is running a crawl
with a list of companies they don't like
that they want people to target these
people are pathetic and this is why
you know i i don't necessarily want to
open up this can of worms right now
but some of you know that i've done
interviews before with uh
sometimes it's with enlightened
centrists sometimes it's with anti-woken
sometimes it's just random callers when
we open up the phone lines
who will say david you're not talking
enough and being clear about
your principle what is your principle
about abcd
and as i've pointed out many times i
have no issue talking about principles
but there's two problems
with the talking only about principles
one
you end up in a philosophical
theoretical black hole
that does very little to help you figure
out real world situations
most real world situations aren't
resolved
in any sensible way by just saying
let me run the facts through my
principles and then i get an answer
the hard work actually is understanding
how to balance
values principles and the facts on the
ground that's really the work and so
i don't find it particularly i don't
find it innovative
i don't find it productive and i don't
find it particularly enlightened
to sort of recede from the facts of
what's going on on this planet
and to just have conversations about
principles and values i think it helps
you solve very very little and i've said
that before
but the more i don't know about more
important but the more
pressing reason why just the discussions
about principles
in the absence of of reality uh
is a waste of time is that people will
very quickly abandon their principles
anyway these the principle of free
speech and of being against business
regulation
look at how quickly it's gone into the
trash trump has released the list of
companies to boycott
fox news is running a crawl rand paul
excuse me says boycott coca-cola mitch
mcconnell says corporate ceos should
shut up even though his value
is of free speech and corporations doing
whatever they want
why engage with people on values and
principles
when they only stand behind those to the
point that it is politically convenient
and when it's not they abandoned them as
well
all of these people are pathetic they're
all bad faith actors
and in some cases ignorant it's also it
can be a combination of the two